allez c'est pas vu ou pas vu donc au
montage qu'on a vu une candidate de koh
lanta faire des pompes à prêt zéro
retard d'une épreuve
oui c'est écrit c'était doit sa place à
appeler ça allait qui servirent gharbi
et donc non ça c'est bon est ce qu'on a
vu clémentine de koh lanta s'épiler sur
le camp ah oui je les ai tous vus
n'importe quoi en faire on a des images
d'une épreuve qui montre une certaine
pilosité après quelques semaines
d'aventuré regarder
[Musique]
malgré son petit gabarit clémentine a du
mal
[Musique]
à trélon ça revient à la mode ça revient
à la mode c'est qu'elle le faisait déjà
parce que ça ça bouge pas comme ça en
quelques semaines à oui c'est vrai non
pas toi qui connais bien moi je suis une
nickel mais karen jour 40 jours dans mes
carnets ben oui dans sa séquence you
mais oui j ai très bien merci mais je
tourne avec gégé de koh lanta inventé
une nage à ses plus grands moments de
koh lanta relations et après j'aurais
des images de concerts rappeler quand il
a nagé chez nous sur la tête de ma mère
c'était la première prime ici qu'on a
essayé
il avait acheté dans une scène je vous
montrais ça juste après pour l'instant
regarder le fun c'est au tour de gégé de
s'élancer le doyen va devoir ont un
toucher doux et et revenir s'il ne veut
pas de disqualifier son équipe
ça y est gégé a touché la bouée mais ils
paniquent et ils n'arrivent plus du tout
avancé chez j'ai fait du surplace il ne
parvient pas à rejoindre le ponton à la
nage vous rappelle qu avant de repartir
il faut que gégé est passé a dit le
témoin
[Musique]
alors il était venu dans un prennent de
tpm plus on l'avait fait nager dans une
piscine pour voir s'ils avaient
progressé pas trop âgées
attention j'ai bâti c'est parti
[Musique]
ah ah
et s'était cogné le policier visé
il est était pas l'air est elle très
construite avec gégé de koh lanta jeter
dans tpm paix l'époque de france 4 je ne
m'en lasse pas il est avec nous par
téléphone
oui c'est d'être denis brogniart un de
mes plus gros fous rires de l'histoire
de tpm père garde gégé est ce que vous
allez venir nous voir dans touche pas à
mon poste à semaine prochaine gg oui
vous vous voulez venir dans touche pas
vous passez vous me connaissez oui j'ai
est ce que vous allez venir dans touche
pas à mon poste
[Musique]
viser une dernière modification est ce
que vous allez venir dans touche pas à
mon poste la semaine prochaine j me
poser gg tu m'entends c'est denis ja ja
cyril hanouna qui voudrait savoir si tu
vas venir la semaine prochaine dans son
émission touche pas à mon poste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
gégé est ce que tu viens la semaine
prochaine dans touche pas à mon poste
est ce que tu veux venir dans l'émission
la semaine prochaine et qu'est ce que
j'admire regard en 2000
une idée formidable denis brogniart
vraiment je les adore les cherry est ce
qu'on a vu une candidate de koh lanta
chanter juste après son élimination à
lui livra peu ou pas allez y chanter
quoi libérer des vraies dents voilà
avancement vous le savez votre rêve
s'arrête ici je vais vous demander de
leur dire au revoir
et puis de les quitter
[Musique]
je ne vous oublie pas non jamais c'est
creux de moi dans ma vie et je vous
retrouverai ou 1
non
en tout cas encore une bonne info de
maxime de la version all stars wayne est
connu pour chanter du disney sont l
ailier j'avais sympathique elle aussi
est ce qu'on avait un serpent passé de
koh lanta la veste de florent pagny en
moins est ce qu'on a vu un camp dit une
candidate de koh lanta très énervé face
à un candidat très calme
c'était en 2001 lors de la toute
première édition denis brogniart
n'apparaissait pas l'antenne il faisait
seulement dérive n'est pas la voix off
sur la première édition
exactement
regardez vous allez voir que faire ce
choix se fasse attaquer violemment à
williams mais pourquoi tu veux donner le
nom avant parce qu'on vous remet on doit
rester notre tu m'agresses oui si je
pouvais je te casser la gueule tu vois
que je casserai lagarde si je pouvais tu
es en train d'hurler tuer la vie c'est
notre c'est pas une et qu'une sale
gueule tu te fais que m'insulter
cheville vraiment déçu feller si ça peut
te met bas ce connard
[Applaudissements]
la première saison de koh lanta koh
lanta sur tf1 il ne savait pas comment
l'amener à l'antenne ils ont fait le
montage pense une dizaine de fois et
l'époque c'est franck fermé lyon qui a
refait une énième fois le montage qui
est devenu patron de la chaîne exact on
était en plein love story était femme
était très inquiet sur l'issue de
l'émission et ben en tout cas ça a
cartonné à bas mais c'était ce qu'on a
vu est ce qu'on a vu dylan lancé marc de
mocassins après son passage dans koh
lanta ah bah oui c'est dylan du trabendo
dit la douane bah oui je n'ai pas eu
cette émission c'est le gars qui fait
des moquées convocation au québec
parties la première fois et pour
survivre dans la jungle regarde non mais
pas sa machette mais ici attention après
le jeu viendra forêt avec un jogging
parce qu'on chauffe ça c'est trop
dangereux du coup j'ai envie sa
chaussure
le mocassin de jungle une belle
innovation de dylan
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est de la production c'est pas
possible ça vous énerve mais très
franchement j'ai un jeu de survie en
mocassins
mais certains programmes et honnêtement
limite ça peut être dangereux feront
alors il a de retour cette année dans
l'eau là-bas il est avocat tao sinon il
en basket c'est à dire voilà sinon
espadrilles fait du vélo en ville et sur
dubai blue bombers
sincèrement je ne sais pas si c'est la
production mais moi des copains comme ça
qu'ils vont faire de la montagne par
exemple avec des jolies quant à eux tout
comme ça j'en connais plein nord mémoire
dont il dit que la ville était comme une
à citer des noms
wen et c'était des prénoms genre ferment
tous un nid merci merci toi si tu
maintenant la parole alors et je peux
pas m'empêcher de vous diffuser les
images de moundir qui pètent la wi fi
nation c'est pour moi vraiment si ce
calcul dans koh lanta rien
pourquoi ne dépend plus tard éducation 7
au 15 heures on adore voilà